Is writer's block and finding your voice
really a writing problem? Or are you
just missing someone to talk to? Well,
after coaching a group of 25 writers in
an experimental non-fiction writing
sprint, I found that the biggest
improvement that you can make to your
writing has nothing to do with forcing
yourself to write and just pressing
publish or learning about sentence
structure and word choice. It has to do
with the people who you surround
yourself with. So, in this video, I'm
going to show you the kinds of
opportunities that can come your way
when you start writing online, the two
kinds of writers for whom writing online
is a good thing, what's missing from
most of the online writing courses out
there, and how I leveraged AI to
accidentally create one of the most high
value pieces of this online writing
sprint. And no, it had nothing to do
with writing with AI. But first, I've
got to tell you a little bit about how
this got started because it's a great
example of the kinds of opportunities
that you attract to yourself when you
start sharing your ideas and expertise
online. So about a year ago to the day,
I shared a video which was about six
different types of books that you can
write. And for each one of these books,
I gave an example. So, there are all
kinds of books, but the one that I ended
on is one that I called a gift because
these types of books seem to be written
not as a commodity. That's really what I
wanted to contrast it with. These books
aren't a commodity. They're not really
entering into the marketplace of
commodities and cash exchange. They're
passed along in a gift economy. And so,
the example that I gave of a gift book
was Paul Millard's The Pathless Path.
Now Paul wrote this book after he left
his corporate uh career. He was a
consultant and he left it. And the whole
idea of the book is trying to find your
own path, right? Rejecting the scripts
that society gives you and carving out
your own weird path and really being
yourself. And that book really took off.
I think to date it sold something like
80,000 copies. And eventually Penguin
Random House came up to Paul and offered
to buy the rights to it. G they were
going to give him $200,000 for the
rights to the book and he turned them
down because it was a bad deal based on
the way the book had been selling and
what they had to offer. But the point is
not so much about Paul's book. It's
about what happened after I made this
video talking about that book because I
shared that video and then shortly after
I got a message from Paul and he said
something quite flattering to the effect
of uh that nobody had quite written
about no nobody had captured what he was
trying to do in this book as well as I
had. And that was great. So, we struck
up a little conversation. I knew that he
was in Asia. I live in South Korea. So,
I said, "If you're ever out here, drop
me a line." And he said, "Oh, funny
enough, I'll be in Busousan in a couple
of months time." Now, Busousan is
actually the city where I live. So, I
thought, "Well, that's insane. Hello.
Let's meet up when you're here." Now, at
this point of the story, it's actually
important that I mention that at this
time in my YouTube career, I was really
searching for people who were
independently motivated to write because
I'm an English professor and essentially
all the students that I've ever had are
like a captive audience. You know, they
have to be there. They have to follow my
program. And since I've been building
this platform here on YouTube, I've been
trying to make content for people who
want to write. And so, I've been trying
to figure out who are these people. And
so fast forward a few months later and
Paul and I meet here in Busousan and we
get lunch and then we have a coffee and
he lets me know that there are these
people in his community. He has a big
WhatsApp group where uh people who read
and enjoyed his books uh talk and they
share and sometimes they spin up cool
projects. And somebody in that group had
sent out a message like that day putting
the word out to people that he wanted to
organize a writing project for the
summer so that they could basically
everybody could write an essay and then
they could publish it together in like a
pathless path zen. And so Paul and I
were talking about it and he said that
they had done it once before but it was
a lot of work on his part and he wasn't
really sure who wanted to take it on. I
said well can I do it? And he said sure.
So just like that I put out a call. I
pulled the community. I said, "Who wants
to do this?" I got a list of about 30 or
40 people who who were interested in
doing this project. And as I said, I was
trying to transition out of this teacher
role. So, I was really sensitive to not
trying to prescribe a shape or a
structure for this sprint. I really
wanted to understand what these people
wanted and what their problems were and
then from the bottom up design a course
that solves their problems and meets all
their needs. So it was really cool the
way that it all came together. And over
the next two weeks after that point I
had about 30 one-on-one 30inut
interviews. And that was really intense
but I learned a lot. And so there were
all kinds of people who filled out this
survey and did these interviews with
probably at least one from every time
zone and from all different walks of
life and all different levels of
experience. Some of them had done online
writing courses before, others had never
published online before. But what I
learned is that broadly they could be
put into two buckets. And you can let me
know in the comments which one of these
you fall into or if there's a different
set of problems that you come to this
channel for. But essentially what I
learned from this group of writers is
that uh the two problems are one group
wanted to learn how to finish what they
start right so they've started writing
essays and memoirs before but they never
quite finish them and they sit in an old
drive somewhere and they never get
published online. So that group really
wanted a kind of forcing function some
accountability to finally publish their
first essay or two. Now, a second group
has already solved that problem, but
what they wanted help with was what we
could broadly define as finding your
voice, right? So, they they found that
their pros was a little bit flat.
They've tried to learn some more
advanced um structures and patterns that
they could use to incorporate things
like storytelling and um and even, you
know, copywriting in the background,
right? So they're trying this kind of
mishmash of all these different
techniques and to some effect, but
nothing quite feels like them. And of
course, there's this AI problem as well,
right? If they if they're having a
writing problem, they use AI to varying
degrees, but what they find is that it's
kind of they're losing their voice and
so they're not happy with the quality of
what they've been publishing. So those
were the two big problems that we
decided this course would be designed to
solve. And I wanted to learn from the
best writing courses out there. So there
were, as I mentioned, a lot of these
members had done writing courses before.
Two popular ones are ship 30 for30 with
Nicholas Cole and Dicky Bush. And the
other one is uh Right of Passage with
David Prell and Will Mannon and Dan
Sleman. And I wanted to learn the best
and the worst from those courses so that
I could avoid their mistakes and
incorporate their best benefits. And so
one thing one thing that I learned about
the ship 30 course if if you're not
familiar with this course then
essentially it's really focused on
getting participants to publish 30
essays in 30 days. Now they have to kind
of play fast and loose with their
definition of an essay in order to make
that work. So they teach people to write
um mini essays I think they're called or
essentially like a 500word text that you
can take a screenshot of and share
online and it's great for Twitter and
that kind of thing because you're
essentially sharing a picture. So that's
one course and a great thing about that
course which I incorporated into our own
in our own way is that that course one
of the first things they do is they pair
you up with a partner. One participant
told me that that that was the coolest
part of the course is that immediately
they were paired up with a partner and
that was a kind of accountability
partner. So you check in with them every
day. Hey, how's your writing going? Hey,
what did you publish today? Let's read
it. Let me share it. So that was cool.
Um but the downside of that course I was
reported that um they never really got
instruction in writing craft. So it
solves the first problem of getting
people to, you know, just press publish
and get your work out there. But the
thing that it was lacking was
instruction in craft. And so people who
were more interested in developing their
own individual writing style or your own
writing voice were not well served by
that course. Now the second course was
right of passage. And I have to say
people spoke so highly of this course. I
never participated in either, but just
hearing what people reported about the
right of passage course made it see
sound amazing. And these people are
really like it's still a tight community
and I think a lot of the people who had
done it are looking for something just
like that. Again, they're kind of
chasing that dragon. They want something
that is focused on community and a kind
of group coordinated experience. But a
lot of those cohort-based courses like
Thiago Fortes and Ali Abdolls and David
Prell, they all came up at the same time
um around the pandemic in the creator
economy. And it was fantastic because it
brought all these people together who
were otherwise feeling quite isolated.
But basically all of those creators
burned out. They they couldn't sustain
that format because the the cohort-based
course, it really requires a big buildup
leading up to it. And I it's kind of
like if you have an an audience through
your social media, you're kind of
warming them up through your content and
then when by the time they're ready to
buy from you, they're gone from cold to
hot. But then your cohort-based course
kind of evaporates all your hot audience
if you're picturing water now in this
metaphor. And so after you do that
cohort course, you then need to go back
to a big kind of content push to get
more people from cold to hot. So it's
exhausting and all those people
eventually burned out uh burned the
course down and started something new.
So all the participants though from that
right of passage course were looking for
something like that and that's what they
told me. The community was kind of the
most beneficial thing. The downside of
the right of passage course as was
reported to me is that again they were
really looking for instruction on craft.
Now I think right of passage did a
better job than 3030 uh ship 30 for30 in
terms of teaching craft but people who
had higher as and the the things that
they taught you about craft would be
really good for that first group of
people who just want to get started
right it's really cool to learn some
little trick uh and you know that might
make you feel like you've really learned
something useful but at a very soon
point in your development as a writer
you'll find that the content that they
teaching um about writing craft was
limited and I think the people who now
successfully thanks to those courses had
found more of a regular rhythm in their
publishing were looking for something a
little bit deeper a little bit more
useful in terms of writing craft
instruction and so I thought this might
really be where I can shine because I've
been teaching non-fiction writing for
about 10 years now at the university
level and so those were the two big
problems that I wanted to solve with
this course and so it was kind of cool
like to design this course. I really
didn't know what shape it was going to
take because then keep in mind we have
all these different people in different
time zones and they wanted a coordinated
experience like right of passage but
they were like spread out across the
world and it was really challenging to
think about how to do that. And so the
format that we came to is really
interesting but before we get to that I
just want to tell you about how I used
AI to create uh what some people
reported as being the most valuable kind
of side benefit of this course. So
essentially after doing you know 30 odd
uh one-on-one interviews I had all these
transcripts and this was actually just
when Claude had released Fable 5 uh and
I had upgraded to Max for that. So, I
was really kind of putting it through
its paces. And one of the things that I
had to do was scan through all those
transcripts
and based on the everything they said,
you know, the location, where they live,
their experiences, the kinds of things
that they write, um, problems that
they're dealing with, the field that
they work in, whatever, I said, try to
find three people who you would like to
introduce them to because nobody knows
each other. So, now they're in this
group. We had we had this WhatsApp group
at the beginning and I wanted to make
some introductions. So I used AI to kind
of find like the strongest matches
between people and then I had it I
connected it to my Gmail and I had a
draft all these emails to everybody
saying, "Hey, based on what we talked
about, here are three people that I
think you would really hit it off with
and here's the reason why." And so then
I would introduce I would say here's
William. He's an English professor in
Korea. You traveled to Korea years ago.
You mentioned da da da like whatever. I
would just try to find little threads so
I could hook them together. And those
introductions led to a lot of like inter
like people would just meet up and hang
out and talk based on that introduction.
And it's led to I mean there there was
one engineer, a software engineer,
programmer who started talking to
another person in the cohort who was
like um community a consultant like he
would basically help people develop
their coaching offers and that kind of
thing. And so he basically helped this
person. I don't think he's quite left
his job yet, but he's like really made
strides. He's done all this outreach and
like he's about to launch from his
corporate career in computer programming
into a uh software consulting career. So
that was awesome. Um there was another
one. There was somebody here in Korea
who just so happened to be moving to
Kenya. And then we had somebody in the
in the cohort who lived in Kenya. So now
they're meeting up in Kenya. It's like
all these funny connections came out of
it that they didn't sign up for the the
opportunities that will surprise you by
writing online. Like just in the same
way that my video kind of brought me in
contact with Paul Millard and then that
brought me in contact with this group of
people and I never would I I never
engineered that. I didn't plan it by
making this video, but just by virtue of
putting your ideas out there, you never
know what really interesting
opportunities will come your way. And
so, I guess it it's it's something like
that. But that was one of the best uses
of AI. Um, you know, as a writing
teacher, I'm always pulling my hair out
over AI. Um, it's one of the hottest
topics in this in this space of writing.
But if we can just set us aside AI
writing, I think there are a lot of
incredible uses of it. And I'm going to
tell you about one more amazing use that
I used. We essentially designed our own
community software and I think I
accidentally reinvented Facebook from
first principles but we'll get to that
in a second because I want to tell you
about the class format and the way that
we designed this course to solve those
two problems that is get started writing
and uh find your voice. So how do we
design a format that will help us solve
both of those problems? Well a few
things. So one is that in my teaching
like at the university I found that the
best courses that I've ever taught were
smaller group and it could be up to 20
but ideally like 5 to 12 in a seminar as
a kind of round table. The way that I
teach these courses is not that I'm the
sage on the stage. I'm the guide by the
side. That's my position in the
classroom. So in these classes it's the
format is never that I'm giving a
presentation and delivering information
right I'm not standing at the front of
the room lecturing rather we're sitting
in a seminar room and um generally in
you know in my u writing classes it'll
be that there's an assigned reading
everybody in the class will have done
that reading so it'll be an essay we'll
all have read that essay but in that
class one or two people are assigned
what's called a letter of response. So I
wanted to bring in that format into this
online cohort too. That is each online
live session is organized around a
reading. Now generally it's going to be
that we are reading each other's essays
and giving each other feedback on it.
But even at the start I wanted to
practice this letter of response format.
And so the what we did was we assigned
oh I have to tell you about the essays
that we read too but everybody had read
an essay together the same essay and
then we met in a live session to discuss
that essay and not quite discuss because
we're not it's not a book club like
we're not sitting around saying you know
what what did you feel or what did you
think um it it's more analytical we're
trying to figure out how does this essay
work right what is it in the essay where
in the the text Did it do whatever work
that it did on me? And so the format of
these letters of response, I gave
instructions for people about how to
write them, but essentially the idea is
that in a letter of response, you're
responding to the author of the essay.
and you you are asked to move through
the following I don't want to be too
academic rhetorical functions is the
word that's coming to mind but these
moves these different moves that you
want to go through stages so um the
first stage is you need to articulate
what you think the essay is trying to do
right before you you say anything
critical or whatever about the essay you
need to put
in as clear terms as you can what you
think the essay is trying to do? Because
if you misunderstand the essay, then how
is the writer going to accept your
criticism? And conversely, if you can
articulate perfectly what you think the
author is trying to do in the essay and
the author and you put the author in
such a position that they say, "Yes,
that's exactly what I was trying to do
with this essay." Then they will be in a
position to accept your criticism. So,
the first thing you need to do is say
what you think the essay is trying to
do. And the second thing you're asked to
do in this letter of response is to say
what you would steal from this essay.
So, that's bringing your attention to
craft and you're looking at the
techniques that the author employed and
you're saying, "That was really nice.
I'm going to try to use that in my own
essay." And only after you move through
these stages, in fact, I think I'm I'm
forgetting one. I'll look it up later
and I'll leave it in the comments. But
there were I think there were four maybe
even five kind of points that I wanted
these these letters of response to touch
on. But the last one is that only then
are you permitted to share even so much
as one word of criticism. That is only
after you've articulated what you think
the essay is trying to do perfectly.
Only after you have noted something the
author does well. Only then can you say
what was lacking or missing in the
essay. And as I said, we started
practicing this format for two weeks
before I had the writers in the group
submit their own essays. We practiced
this format for two weeks with
professionally published essays. And
this was another thing. See, I wanted it
to be from the bottom up. I did not want
to be coming at them as the sage on the
stage. I did not want to say, "Here's
the curriculum. This is the essay we're
reading tomorrow." What I wanted to do,
because I wanted to create a kind of
culture, like our own culture of taste.
So I wanted to find out what kind of
writing they liked and so among these uh
you know I interviewed like 30 35
writers but in the end there were only
about 25 who uh finally enrolled. So of
these 25 writers I asked each one to
submit two essays that they consider
well written and that was going to give
me an idea of the kind of writing that
they aspire to do and there were some
really interesting submissions I have to
say. What are some ones that come to
mind? Like there was Tim Urban was in
there. Oh, let's see. We read one essay
from George Saunders, right? The brain
dead megaphone. Uh we read another
essay, a recent one from Harpers on uh
on the Goon Squad that that won the mag
the the feature award from the National
Magazine Awards this year that was
really interesting. But there were also
like there was one that was uh what the
the Radius Guide to Chicken. Have you
read this? There's some company I think
in Austin that does like healthy, you
know, grass-fed chicken or whatever. And
this was an explainer of what makes
their chicken well written. And I
thought that or well written, well well
uh well raised and this essay I thought
was one of the most interesting things
that we read. It was very well written.
There was a I'll have to pull up the
list but it was it was a really
interesting list of essays that we went
through and again we spent two so we did
this four days a week. So we went
through eight uh over two weeks we went
through eight letters of response and so
in these live sessions it was really
cool this format we would all meet on
not all of us because not everybody
could join. So I had everybody submit
their times of availability uh with a
kind of heat map. So I just chose the
most available times across this kind of
heat map and then we would meet and in
these sessions two writers were
responsible for writing a letter of
response. So that's a two-page response
to the essay going through the format
that we mentioned a moment ago. And the
session was essentially I would have one
we've all read the essay and now I have
one writer read their response and I
then the other writer reads the response
and I just give them one instruction and
that instruction is something that an
English professor told me years ago
about how to read how to read critically
or how to read well. He said, "All you
need to do to read well is look for
where things are the same and look for
where they're different." And so that's
what I told these writers to do in the
session. I just said, "The other writer
is going to read their letter of
response. Just listen. Listen for when
things are the same as your letter of
response and listen for where they're
different." And so each would read their
letter of response and the other would
look for where things are the same and
different. And then a conversation would
progress over the course of an hour
where we would just say, "Okay, well,
what are some things you agree about?"
Okay, cool. And then we would look into
that. And the the well, in fact, before
they even write these things, like what
we're trying to do is I have them read
it twice because what we're trying to do
in these analyses is to think about how
the text works, right? We want to know
like okay so one I I told them just to
read the essay normally. So read it on
your phone if you want skim if you feel
so compelled to skim. If you feel bored
put it down
read it as you would a reader
and then don't write a thing like put it
down and just try to think. And I told
them to use a voice note too because it
really doesn't matter. So he said, "Use
a voice note and after you read it, just
talk and talk about your feelings, talk
about whatever you think, talk about how
have a natural intuitive response to the
text and then have AI just give you a
bulletoint list of the major, you know,
the main ideas. Now the next day or a
few days later, I want you to put that
in a drawer and then come back to it.
And the on the second reading, I want
you to be more analytical." So for
example, if you say the essay was
boring. Okay, interesting. It's almost
like um like you're doing a body scan of
pain. So that's I I meditate too. And so
when you do that, you know, if you feel
pain, what you train to do is like,
okay, I oh I feel pain. So instead of
like getting up and stopping meditation,
what you do is you're like, "Oh, pain.
Okay, where where's that? Oh, the pain
is in my hip. Okay, uh where does the
pain where is the pain strongest? Okay,
here's where the pain is the strongest.
And then how far does it go? Where where
does it end? And so you just look at it
and you try to understand where is it
and how does it work? And so it's the
same thing with these essays. It's like
okay, you say the essay was boring.
Interesting. Where does the boredom
live? Right? Is is here. Is that the
boredom? This part is more boring than
that part. Oh, this is the most boring
part. Okay. Let's take a really close
look and try to figure out how boredom
works. And so through these letters of
response, and this is one of the big
pieces of feedback that people gave me,
is that it really taught people to read
like a writer. Like you you learn to not
read just as a consumer, as a reader,
but you start to understand how the text
works and how you can set up your text
in order to, you know, have certain
effects on your reader. So that would go
for an hour and in fact we had to
lengthen uh the time of these sessions
from 1 hour to 1 hour and 15 minutes
because eventually when we started doing
this letter of response format with the
writers in our group we needed to give
the writers themselves a chance to
respond and the and they weren't able to
do that during the regular session
because of the second format. The second
format that I incorporated into these
sessions is something that I learned
from a friend of mine who did an MFA at
MIT. So she I don't think you can do a
full MFA at MIT, but she had studied
whatever math and then she did like a
minor in creative writing. And she told
me that her professor was Yuno Diaz. I
said, "Oh, that's interesting. Like tell
me what your what your class is like."
And she told me that in those seminars
whenever your work is is being
workshopped there's only one rule which
is that when people when you submit your
your short story or whatever it is uh
for feedback in your seminar the only
rule is that you're not allowed to say
anything that entire seminar you have to
sit there while everybody else has read
your essay and they're talking about it.
Maybe they're saying nice things. Maybe
they're misinterpreting things. Doesn't
matter. you can't rise to the defense of
your essay. And I thought that was
brilliant because that puts you in the
actual position of publishing. Like when
you publish, that's what it is. Your
text is out there. You can't rise to its
defense. It's done. What's done is done.
And so I really wanted to do that in
these sessions, too. I wanted to make it
so that the writers can't clear up any
ambiguity. And I also needed to make
sure that the people giving the letters
of response were free to say what they
really thought. So in these sessions, I
would have those writers turn off their
mic and camera. So they were there, they
heard us talking about the text, but we
never addressed them. We were never
having to do the, you know, the um
feedback sandwich, you know, nice thing,
bad thing, nice thing, whatever. We were
we were free and we would almost forget
about them. And then at the end after 1
hour, I would say, "Okay, let's bring in
uh John or whatever, you know, and then
John would turn his camera and his mic
back on and he's heard everything that
we've said for the past hour and uh and
we would answer any questions that came
up for the last 15 minutes." So that was
the format that we settled on. And we
settled on that format because it solved
both problems. It got people writing
because you had a you had a deadline and
a due date to submit your essay. It
helped people develop uh notes on craft.
Everything we talked about was about
craft and voice. But importantly,
it allowed me to relate to them not as a
sage on the stage, right? I wasn't at
the front of the room saying here's the
way to write well and here's what the
problem is. No, I would just the session
would proceed by the two other me
community members talking about their
responses and it it was just very
emergent. And what's really cool, I'm
going to start turning this into
content. I now have a database of all of
our transcripts. So, I have all the
notes about uh style and tone and like
writing craft that emerged spontaneously
from the bottom up. So, stay tuned
because I'm that's really going to be
the content of this show for the the
next season. I'm going to be sharing a
lot of things that we learned. But
setting aside those style tips, what I
have to say is that the biggest lesson
in this two-month writing sprint, at
least for me, is that the real product
of a course like this is not in the
content itself. Like there are a lot of
cool writing tools that we can talk
about and you can learn and those are
useful, but the real value of doing a
writing course like this is the
opportunity to join a small group of
what you could call beta readers. But we
don't I I I've heard that term before
and it sounds a little bit too much like
product development. Beta readers are
let's call them early readers. It
probably means roughly the same thing
but early readers is more to the point.
Early readers are people who you trust
and they're people who you respect and
by whom you want to be respected.
And if you are in a community where a
community of practice where those people
have developed a culture of sharing each
other's work and giving feedback and all
the trust that comes with that and there
are a certain set of practices such as
the letter of response and guidelines
around that and you you trust this
community and you feel that they're
qualified. See, because here's the
thing. In a lot of these other writing
courses, part of their offer is that you
can get feedback on your writing, but
they would farm that out to the
participants themselves. So, some of the
feedback that I got from some of these
cohort members is that in these other
writing courses, they didn't really feel
like the feedback that they were
receiving was qualified and it certainly
wasn't governed by this community of
practice that I told you about with the
letter of response. So, you know, people
are afraid they don't even know how to
talk about a text. They they might just
take some bogus writing rule that they
learned online from like a Gary Provice
meme and say, "Oh, you should really
vary your sentence length." Like things
that just aren't really, it was lacking.
The feedback that they were getting was
lacking. And so by contrast to that,
what I learned is that in a community of
practice like this, when there is a
culture and a kind of set practice
around the way that we give feedback so
that you know what to expect and you
have invested trust in that community. I
think by doing that you position
yourself into the right relationship
through which writer's block and finding
your voice, those two problems get
solved automatically because as I said
at the beginning of this video, you
never have writer's block when you're
talking to somebody. And you never worry
about finding your voice or your
speaking style being flat or or
inauthentic whenever you're talking to
somebody. Why is that? Well, whenever
you're talking to somebody, let's say a
friend, let's say somebody who you
respect, somebody by whom you want to be
respected, you choose your words
carefully. You choose your words not
only to to communicate what you're
trying to say, but also to accurately
reflect your relationship with that
person, right? to show them respect, to
notice the things that they're
interested in, to stop yourself from
rambling t in in conversation. It would
be about turn taking. Obviously, you
don't do that in writing, but there are
all these kind of social cues that get
passed telepathically whenever we are
speaking to somebody and we make our and
all of those cues are upstream of our
language choices. So when you know who
you're talking to and you like that
person and you want them to like you
back, then all these problems about
writing voice and uh you know get
writer's block vanish. It happens. All
of those writer's choices are downstream
of your relationship to that person with
whom you're in a conversation with. And
what I'm saying is that in a course like
this, when you join a community of
people with whom you have exactly that
relationship, you know who they are, you
trust them, you like them, you want them
to like you, your voice emerges
spontaneously. And that was one of the
biggest pieces of feedback that I got in
the exit interviews that I did with
everybody. This format of a letter of
response and the kind of tight-knit
community that came from this routined
practice helped people solve those
problems automatically. They never got a
single lesson. And this was one of the
criticisms that they had. So in version
two, which I'm developing now, if you
want to keep updated about it, sign up
to my mailing list. I'm going to send
out updates whenever whenever it's
ready. Um but in version two there there
will be more curriculum because some of
the people especially from right of
passage told me that they did want to
actually learn something that they could
then practice right like there were
things that you could learn that were
kind of arising spontaneously in these
seminar sessions kind of like a seminar
room at like an MFA um but there was no
like content library that they could go
to. So if you miss that session you're
never going to get that lesson. So in
version two there will be more of a
curriculum. But the point is that even
without that curricula people were still
solving the problem of voice and writing
style just by coming into relation with
this community of people. So in version
two that's really something that I'm
going to preserve. and putting a fence
around it to really make sure that that
aspect of the community, not just the
community because courses just kind of
tack on a community onto the other end
of the course and and they consider it a
done deal. But the important thing here
was a community of practice that we had
a shared practice that you know as
different as we were we all had the same
practice like the same system that we
were practicing and then through that
practice we were developing our own
culture and our own kind of intrribal
trust. That was the really valuable
thing and that was the thing that solved
the problem without formally solving it.
Right? We never taught people here's how
to find your voice or you know just hit
publish and you know like nothing like
that. It was just through that
community, the real community, the
community of practice that those two
problems were solved. And so version two
of the course is coming. If you want to
learn more about it, just sign up to my
newsletter. But for now, if you want to
solve writer's block, then I am not
going to tell you to discipline your way
through it or just press publish.
Instead, I'm going to get you to watch
this video right here because it is my
unfiltered advice for how I got through
writer's block and it might surprise
you. So, be sure to go check it out.